nous sommes avec la légion géorgienne
conjointement avec d'anciens militaires
ou policiers américains ils entraînent
ces ukrainiens se battre sur le front
les géorgiens ont l'expérience de la
guerre contre la russie ils se sont
battus avec l'otan en afghanistan et il
compte bien leur transmettre leurs
compétences
nous les géorgiens comprendre mieux la
russie que quiconque parce que nous
avons souffert de leur agression plus
que n'importe qui le monde a vu comme la
russie est dangereuse on doit vaincre
l'ennemi
car s'il n'est pas mis hors d'état de
nuire les prochains sur la liste sont
les géorgiens les pays baltes la pologne
et le reste de l'europe viendra ensuite
l'écrasante majorité des soldats
géorgiens se battent sur le front mais
une unité parcourt le pays pour former
les ukrainiens aux techniques de combat
je crois que chaque citoyen ukrainien
doit protéger notre pays et
nous avons des familles des amis que
nous devons protéger tout le monde doit
le faire c'est notre obligation
on absorbe comme des éponges tout ce qui
pourrait nous servir à l'avenir j'ai
besoin de six mecs qui n'ont pas peur de
se mouiller et voilà que deux mecs se
met ici
environ 30% de la légion géorgiennes
sont des volontaires étrangers comme
brad qui était policier aux états unis
il est venu prêter main forte aux
instructeurs j'ai les compétences pour
venir aider je ne pouvais pas rester à
la maison à ne rien faire donc tu fais
mes valises je suis monté dans l'avion
et maintenant je suis là c'est
extrêmement facile de travailler avec
les ukrainiens ils sont très attentifs
et l'élément clé c'est qu'ils sont très
malins je le vois travailler ensemble
pour résoudre les problèmes
c'est presque comme s'il apprenait tout
seul avant même que j'aie le temps de
leur enseigner quoi que ce soit leur
moral est excellent pour tout le monde à
l'évidence personne est excité à l'idée
de partir au front mais ils sont prêts
depuis que brad et en ukraine il a déjà
formé plus d'un millier de soldats sucre
aignan il nous a expliqué qu'il ne
quitterait pas le pays tant qu un seul
militaire russe serait encore sur le
territoire